right now a rally being held outside el
dorado high school where just over a
week ago police say a student brutally
attacked a teacher madison kimbrough
joins us live with what organizers are
saying madison
this rally started at 3 p.m and as you
can see behind me students teachers and
staff are all in solidarity about
stopping the violence in schools the
rally hosted by the education support
employees association is meant to bring
parents staff and students together to
make it known that violence continues to
be a major problem at our schools and
that it needs to stop the same rhetoric
voiced in an email from superintendent
jarrah on monday as parents received an
email stating that there will be
consequences for violating the student
code of conduct in that email
superintendent jarrah also asked for
parents to be more involved with their
kids during this difficult time and make
sure that the support system they need
is there we plan on talking to some of
the students and teachers here hearing
from those involved in the rally today
about their thoughts on the matter and
why it's so important for them to
participate today that's going to come
up at five and six o'clock here on eight
news now reporting live near el dorado
high school madison kimbrough live local
now